got some administrative work going on
right now one of the umpires is out
in the outfield this is ramon laureano
is he going to lock the door then jump
the fence
frankie's having a laugh at it so he
thinks it's funny he's ready to go
jp crawford swinging a bat really well
going the other way little dink shot
it's going to work
base hit jp crawford about that
trying to finish strong and he's doing
that seven game hitting streak for him
with this base hit inside out swing kind
of tied him up
throw down the second and he's holding
his drop oh he dropped the ball wow
because the ball was there in time
marcus simeon couldn't hold on stolen
base jp crawford is seventh here's ty
france
that'll work here's a little bloop job
coming towards the left fielder and
scoring easily as jp crawford marines
have an early lead
rbi ty france that's his 13th
marco gonzalez they crafted lefty on the
mound one start
against the athletics that was the first
given the double header the a's actually
had a big lead against him he stayed in
long enough to see his offense come back
not overpowering but he knows how to
pitch and it's first and third one out
first pitch to kenneth
roll to the right side softly and then
flip to second to get the out there
france france wanted to tag chris davis
but
he was trying to figure out the best way
to try to turn the double play and
really he was probably not going to be
able to do it so he gets the out run
comes in to score we're tied at one
get back to the top of the order jp
crawford
pulls this one base hit marmillo's
rounding
there's a throw he's in there safely jp
crawford another base hit the mariners
have a 2-1 lead
is hot it's a solid base hit this time
hitting it into right field
running a hole on the right side of the
diamond so it's the top of the fourth
inning from the coliseum tim lopes to
lead it off against frankie montos who's
got six strikeouts
two and two to lopes swinging to miss
truck him out
frankie gets the a strikeout i love a
fastball he's getting the strikeouts
pitch count is rising
facing joseph odom two and two of the
count swinging a foul tip murph holds on
and frankie strikes out the side he's
got
nine see if the ace bats can awaken
so murphy to lead it off and bulls hit
well the right center field
bishop looking up and that one is off
the top of the wall looks like it
may have hit behind the wall but yeah
they're saying it's a double they being
the umpires very difficult for an umpire
to see that and as a result they're
gonna
have new york take a look at it well
yeah what it hits is it hits that round
metal
post it made a lot of contact with the
top of that wall
and or that post part but it looks like
it catches that post
flush and if that's the case that should
be three left turns
and bob melvin's so it's a double yeah
bob melvin may be saying to ted bear
let's talk about the ground rules
so here's the tying run at second base
driven to right field bishop going back
bishop turns around makes the catch
murphy's gonna tag he's gonna
head over to third so the a's will have
the tying run at third
so pinder hits for the second time a's
need a two out hit to tie up this game
and that's a base hit by chad pinder
going the other way
so murphy comes in to score and this
game is tied at two
so it's a two two game sixth inning ten
k's two five innings a couple of walks
so evan white leading it off couple of
strikeouts for white
got him swinging 11 strikeouts from on
top
one and two to marmalayos strike three
called
make an even dozen strikeouts for montas
how about pitch number 108
at 98. probably knows this is it for him
with
petite warming up of course pitch count
is up there
but he's got to be feeling great about
himself helps weights on toe steel swing
and a mist struck him out he strikes out
the side that's
13 strikeouts for frankie montos
what a performance by the big
right-hander mikey mata sensational
performance
13 strikeouts that's a career high last
days pitchers with more in a game
you got to go back to 1995. todd
stottlemeyer struck out 15 royals
gerardo comes in for his 13th appearance
tie game 2-2
going back is lopes in left field
turning around and
that baby's gone nice easy swing from
jake lamb he goes the other way and the
a's grab the lead at three to two
jake lam hops for oppo tacos for
everybody instead
pack your bags all about
next stop pound town
how about it lambo so bases are loaded
for kenna
hirano nothing really going right for
him in this inning
driven toward right center lewis going
back lewis at the wall
and he juggles and he dropped it murphy
will score
kemp will score pinder to third
and kenna with a double that knocks in a
pair it's five to two
three and two the canna the bases are
loaded cannon already has three rbis in
the game
and he walked it cannon will take it
that's another rbi for canna as murphy
scores and it's 6-2
here's bishop up the middle marcus
ranging far to his left quick
throw and it's dug out by olson bishop's
called out and that is the ball game
so the regular season the 60 game
regular season has come to a close now
the ace can
get themselves ready for the wild card
series best of three series in the
american league and that'll start
tuesday right here at the coliseum